[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Stefan Netzeband und ich bin Mirco
Kasimir schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
heute geht es um einen Fall von dem fast
jeder von uns schon mal gehört hat
nämlich den Fall Monika Weimar die in
den 1980er Jahren ihre beiden Töchter
umgebracht haben soll ihr hört aber
nicht nur die Geschehnisse von damals
sondern auch einen Bericht von unserer
Reporterin Lena Zander die viele Jahre
später am heutigen Wohnort war sie hat
außerdem spannende neue Informationen zu
diesem Fall die erst seit diesem
Frühjahr bekannt sind Lena fast jeden
Fall Weimar für uns jetzt erstmal so
zusammen ja der Fall weimar ist ganz
besonders erstmal dadurch dass eine
Mutter ihre beiden Töchter ermordet
haben soll sowas ist in der deutschen
Nachkriegszeit bis dato einmalig gewesen
es gibt zwei Versionen wie der
Tathergang gewesen sein soll und zwar
die erste Version ist die Tag Version da
hat Monika Weimar zuerst ausgesagt dass
die am Morgen des 4 august mit ihren
Kindern gegen 39 aufgestanden ist und
mit ihnen gefrühstückt hat gegen 10 Uhr
seien die Mädchen dann zum Spielen auf
dem Spielplatz hinterm Haus gegangen sie
selbst sie war so ungefähr bis 10 Uhr
beim Einkaufen als sie gegen 12:30
zurückkam hat sie ihren Ehemann
losgeschickt um die Kinder zum Essen zu
holen und angeblich waren die Kinder
dann verschwunden
dann gibt es noch die Nacht Version
Monika Weimar hat nämlich zuerst die
tag-version ausgesagt dann die Nacht
Version und in der Nacht Version hält
sie auch bis heute fest und die lautet
folgendermaßen und zwar sei sie nachts
gegen 3 Uhr vom Tanzen mit dem Liebhaber
Kevin Kurt nach Hause gekommen da hätten
ihre Töchter schon tot in ihren Betten
gelegen sie sollen angeblich erstickt
worden sein von ihrem eigenen Vater
Nachbarn haben angeblich in der Tatnacht
sogar Schreie der Mädchen gehört man
weiß bis heute nicht waren es Carola und
Melanie die da im Todeskampf geschrien
haben das war eine sehr kompakte
Übersicht wir lernen die Beteiligten
jetzt ein bisschen besser kennen Mirko
Monika Böttcher wird am 13 April 1958 in
Hessen in einer Arbeiterfamilie geboren
der Vater arbeitet im Bergbau Monika
macht eine Ausbildung zur
Krankenpflegerin
1977 lernt sie den Kfz-Schlosser
Reinhard zu erkennen die beiden werden
ein Paar und heiraten schon kurze Zeit
später Monika sagt sie sei die Beziehung
aus Torschlusspanik eingegangen muss ich
mal sagen finde ich schräg ich meine da
war sie gerade 19 20 Jahre alt aber in
dieser Zeit und wohl auch in dieser
Beziehung muss alles offenbar ziemlich
schnell gehen genau schon ein weiteres
Jahr später ist das erste Kind da
Melanie die am 22 juli 1979 geboren wird
auch die Wohnsituation ist übrigens sehr
heimlich Monika und Reinhard Leben im
gleichen Haus im hessischen Philippsthal
wie monika's ältere Schwester Barbara
und deren Mann Raymond außerdem wohnt
auch die jüngere Schwester samt Partner
dort so wie monika's Eltern und die Oma
und eine weitere Mitbewohnerin kommt ja
noch am 8 März 1981 dazu da wird die
zweite Tochter Carola geboren fast jeder
hat die beiden Mädchen schon mal auf
einem Foto zusammen gesehen
Melanie strahlt einen aus fröhlichen
blauen Augen an sie ist vielleicht fünf
oder sechs Jahre alt sofort fallen einem
die vielen Sommersprossen auf und das
knallrote Haar es ist so kräftig gelockt
das ist auch durch Haarspangen kaum zu
bändigen ist rechts daneben Carola ein
Kopf kleiner blonde glatte Haare ein
offenes Lachen und die gleiche süße
Stupsnase wie die ältere Schwester die
Geschehnisse vom 4 august 1986 machen
diese süßen Mädchen bald bundesweit
bekannt aber schon vor dem schrecklichen
Ereignissen gibt es Trauer und Konflikte
1983 stirbt der alte Böttcher monika's
Vater und spätestens ab 1985 gibt es
eine Ehekrise bei Monika und Reinhardt
Reinhard Weimar geht in dieser Zeit
mehrfach zum Arzt er leidet unter
Bewusstsein Störungen und
Ohnmachtsanfällen mit diesem Beschwerden
kommt er dann sogar ins Krankenhaus
dort finden die Ärzte Substanzen gegen
kampfanfälle in seinem Urin Reinhard
kann sich das nicht erklären hat Monika
ihrem Mann die Medikamente heimlich
irgendwo reingemischt das wird später
noch ein Gericht beschäftigen aber ohne
konkretes Ergebnis fest steht Monika ist
in ihrer Ehe genauso unglücklich wie
ihre Schwester Barbara in ihrer
die beiden gehen jetzt öfter miteinander
aus dabei lernt Monika den US-Soldaten
Kevin Pratt kennen und beginnt eine
Affäre mit ihm ihr Mann Reinhardt fängt
in dieser unglücklichen Zeit an ins
Bordell zu gehen was dann am 4 august
1986 passiert das lässt sich einteilen
in Dinge die unstrittig sind und um
Abfolgen die bis heute für Diskussionen
sorgen unstrittig ist der vierte August
ist ein Montag in den Schulferien am
Mittag meldet Monika Weimar ihre beiden
Töchter als vermisst was ansonsten
vorgefallen ist schildert Monika Weimar
in ihrer ersten Vernehmung so
die Kinder seien gegen 9.30 aufgestanden
und nach einem kurzen Frühstück gegen 10
Uhr zum Spielplatz neben dem Wohnhaus
gegangen tatsächlich wollen mehrere
Zeugen sie auch wirklich dort gesehen
haben Sie Monika sei zu dieser Zeit in
die Stadt gefahren um Besorgungen zu
machen unter anderem sei sie bei der
Bank gewesen als sie mittags zurückkam
seien die Mädchen verschwunden gewesen
Reinhard Weimar hat an diesem Tag Urlaub
genau wie seine Frau er sagt aus er habe
bis etwa 11:30 Uhr geschlafen und dann
auf seine Frau gewartet die mit dem Auto
weg gewesen und gegen 12:15 Uhr
zurückgekommen sei Monika sagt sie sei
zwischen 12:30 Uhr und 12:40 Uhr
zurückgekommen und habe dann das
Mittagessen vorbereitet dann habe sie
ihren Mann Reinhard gebeten die Mädchen
vom Spielplatz zu holen aber diese sein
verschwunden gewesen
bevor wir zu anderen Version dieses
Tages kommen müssen wir die traurige
Gewissheit berichten am 7 August also
drei Tage nach dem Verschwinden der
weimar-mädchen entdeckt der Busfahrer
Hans-Georg Führer auf einem Parkplatz
die Leiche eines siebenjährigen Mädchens
10 Autominuten von philipsthal entfernt
es ist der Körper von Melanie Weimar in
einem vier Kilometer entfernten Himbeer
Gestrüpp findet die Polizei anderthalb
Stunden später auch deren zwei Jahre
jüngere Schwester Carola jemand hatte
Melanie erstickt und Carola erwirkt am
28 August wird Monika Weimar unter
Mordverdacht festgenommen einen Tag
später präsentiert sie eine andere
Version der Ereignisse die Nacht Version
sie sei in der Nacht zum 4 august gegen
3 Uhr nach Hause gekommen und habe ihren
Ehemann im Kinderzimmer vorgefunden
beide Kinder seien zu diesem Zeitpunkt
bereits tot aber noch körperwarm gewesen
ihr Mann habe hysterisch geheult und
irre reingeschaut dann habe er die
Leichen mit dem Auto weggebracht und bei
seiner Rückkehr gesagt jetzt kriegt
keiner mehr die Kinder
Reinhard habe ich auch verraten wo die
Leichen nun lägen warum bitte will
Monika all das mitbekommen und trotzdem
Tage lang geschwiegen haben warum machte
sie am Mittag noch die Vermisstenmeldung
und vor allem warum fuhr sie dann noch
in die Stadt aus Mitleid mit Reinhard
sagt sie jetzt sie sei ja sogar einen
Tag darauf noch zum Ablageort Gefahren
den ihr Mann genannt hatte um sich
nämlich von den Mädchen zu verabschieden
dort habe sie aber nur Carolas Leiche
gefunden Monika zeigt in der mittleren
auch zwei angeblich anonyme Hand
geschriebene Briefe sie will sie am 12
und 15 August erhalten haben im ersten
steht das ist die Strafe es tut mir leid
um die Kinder aber es musste sein auf
dem anderen erst die Kinder die nur zur
Qualen jetzt bist du bald dran von wem
der Auftrag kommt kannst du dir wohl
denken dass Manöver ist durchschaubar
die Spurensicherung findet heraus dass
Monika selbst diese Briefe geschrieben
hat mittlerweile redet ganz Deutschland
über den schrecklichen Mord an zwei
kleinen Mädchen über die fragwürdigen
Umstände und die widersprüchlichen
Aussagen zum Prozess gegen Monika kommt
es erst ein dreiviertel Jahr später die
Weimars hatten sich inzwischen scheiden
lassen Monika trug wieder ihren
Mädchennamen Böttcher vor dem
Landgericht Fulda beteuert sie ihre
Unschuld Richter Klaus burmut muss sich
durch zahlreiche Indizien kämpfen und
durch Widersprüche so wollen ja mehrere
Zeugen Melanie und Carola am 4 august
gegen 11 Uhr auf dem sandigen Spielplatz
gesehen haben aber an den Leichen und
der Kleidung gab es keinerlei Sandspuren
belastet wurde die Mutter nach Ansicht
des Gerichts durch Fasern von einer
ihrer Blusen sie waren auf dem T-Shirt
sichergestellt worden dass die tote
Melanie angehabt hatte Monikas Schwester
Brigitte und ihr Mann Raymond dir direkt
über der Familie wohnten sagen übrigens
auch beide aus und zwar eine sehr
interessante Aussage sie hätten in der
Nacht vom dritten auf den vierten August
Carola Weinen gehört daraufhin hätten
sie gemeinsam in der Wohnung der Weimars
nach dem Rechten gesehen Carola habe in
die Hose gemacht Brigitte erliert habe
sie umgezogen Melanie die sonst meist
sofort aufgewacht sei habe dagegen
reglos in ihrem Bett gelegen ob die
Eltern in der Wohnung waren hätten sie
nicht überprüft schließlich hält Richter
burmut eine tag-version für erwiesen
nach der Monika weimar am Vormittag des
4 august mit ihren Mädchen losgefahren
ist sie tötete und die Leichen ablegte
aber mit diesem Schuldspruch war die
Sache nicht erledigt noch lange nicht
Lena Zander fasst zusammen es gab
daraufhin wirklich ein
jahrelanges Justiz tauen ziehen kann man
fast sagen und zwar 13 Jahre lang hat
das gedauert es gab drei Prozesse im
ersten Prozess wurde Monika Weimar
schuldig gesprochen zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt sie ging auch ins Gefängnis
dann gab es eine Wiederaufnahme ein
neues Verfahren in dem Monika Weimar
freigesprochen wurde
das ganze setze sich vor 1999 mit einem
dritten Verfahren in dem Monika Weimar
dann wieder wegen Mordes zu lebenslange
Haft verurteilt wurde im Sommer 2006
kommt Monika Böttcher frei diesmal für
immer die Strafe ist abgesessen nach 15
Jahren Haft wird sie wegen guter Führung
aus dem Frauengefängnis Frankfurt
entlassen sechs Jahre später wird ihr
Ex-Mann Reinhard Weimar tot aufgefunden
alles spricht dafür dass er in seinem
Elternhaus an einem Herzinfarkt
gestorben ist aber damit angesichts
aller vorhergehenden Dramen keine
Gerüchte aufkommen ordnen die Behörden
eine Obduktion an die das Herz Versagen
bestätigt und noch ein paar Jahre später
im Sommer 2022 macht sich bildreporterin
Lena Zander noch mal auf Spurensuche im
Fall Weimar wir sind noch mal in das
Dorf der toten Mädchen gefahren das ist
in Philippsthal in Hessen gewesen und
haben mit Nachbarn und auch mit damals
Zeitzeugen noch mal gesprochen und man
hat gemerkt gerade bei der älteren
Generation
hat sich das wirklich festgesetzt es ist
immer noch Thema wenn man fragt nach dem
Fall Monika Weimar erinnern sich viele
Leute daran es waren damals auch sehr
viele Menschen an der Suchaktion
beteiligt weil die Kinder ja drei Tage
lang verschwunden gewesen sind die
Nachbarn und Anwohner haben weitgebiete
durchkämmt sind eigenständig los und das
ist ein kleiner Ort sowas spricht sich
schnell rum
und die Meinung der Menschen war von
Anfang an klar als Täter kommen nur zwei
in Frage entweder Mutter Monika oder
Vater Reinhard
bei Mundharmonika eine Affäre hatte mit
einem US-Soldaten und sowieso nicht ganz
so beliebt im Ort gewesen ist hat sich
das meinungslager schnell gebildet
hauptsächlich ist meiner Meinung dass
Monika Weimar die beiden Mädchen auf dem
Gewissen hat obwohl sie die Morde bis
heute bestreitet das war aber nicht die
einzige Recherche unterwegs in Hessen
außerdem haben wir uns gefragt was macht
Monika Weimer wie lebt sie heute wenn
man seine Töchter seine eigenen Kinder
verloren hat ist das für jedes
Elternteil eine traumatische schlimme
Situation wenn man dann aber auch noch
die Kinder selbst umgebracht hat kann
man danach noch ein normales Leben
führen und diese Frage haben wir uns
gestellt ich habe Monika Weimar
ausfindig gemacht sie lebt in einer
Stadt in Hessen sie führt dort
eigentlich ein man kann schon fast sagen
spießiges Leben ihre Nachbarn vor Ort
wissen auch zum Teil um wen es sich
handelt man muss auch dazu sagen Monika
Weimar heißt heute nicht mehr Weimar
sondern Böttcher weil sie geschieden
sich halt scheiden lassen von ihrem
damaligen Mann der inzwischen verstorben
ist und Frau Böttcher lebt in einer
spießigen
Reihenhaussiedlung wo es auch mehr
Familienhäuser gibt
was interessant zu beobachten ist war
das Gegenüber das Wohnhauses eine Kita
ist sprich sie ist jeden Tag mit Kindern
mit Kinderlachen mit Fröhlichkeit
konfrontiert was ich mir auch sehr
schwierig vorstelle
ich weiß dass Monika Weimar inzwischen
ins Leben zurückgefunden hat dass sie
gerne Fußball mag dass es ihr gut geht
dass sie mit der ganzen Situation den
Umständen entsprechend gut zurechtkommen
weil sie ist ja nicht nur Mörderin sie
war auch oder ist auch Mutter
und das ist vielleicht eine gute
Nachricht wenn man das in dem
Zusammenhang so sagen kann und damit
sind wir wie versprochen beim spannenden
aktuellen Teil denn vielleicht wird der
Fall Weimar der Mord an den Mädchen
Melanie und Carola noch einmal
aufgerollt es gibt jetzt auch wieder
neue Hoffnung für Monika war immer und
zwar leidet ihr Verteidiger Gerhard
Strate wohl bald ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren in die Wege es
war ja bisher so das habe ich eben schon
erzählt dass nur zwei Täter in Frage
gekommen sind Mutter oder Vater jetzt
gibt es aber eine neue Spur die einen
dritten Täter ins Rennen bringt
und dieser dritte Täter ist kein
Unbekannter das ist der
Ex-Ehemann von Monika Weimar Schwester
ich muss jetzt leider ein bisschen auch
so nimmt man den Zusammenhang versteht
die Weimars haben in einem Haus gewohnt
Mehrfamilienhaus mehreren Wohnungen
darin hat auch Monika Weimars Mutter
gelebt und ihre Schwester Brigitte mit
ihrem Ehemann so und Monika Weimar war
ja zur Tatnacht aus sie war mit ihrem
Geliebten feiern normalerweise hat
Monika Weimars Mutter immer auf die
Kinder aufgepasst in solchen Momenten
die war aber gesundheitlich verhindert
weil sich den Arm gebrochen hatte also
waren Reinhard Weimar und der Ehemann
von Brigitte Weimer im Haus nicht in
derselben Wohnung die Mädchen hatten
geschlafen sondern oben drüber
und dieser Mann ist jetzt in den Fokus
gerückt weil er 1999 inzwischen zurück
in Amerika getrennt von Brigitte
verurteilt wurde wegen sexuellen
missbraucht er hat zwei Mädchen in
demselben Alter gewesen sind wie Melanie
und Carola sexuelle missbraucht dann ist
dafür 16 Jahre hinter Gittern gewandert
und jetzt ist es natürlich das Bestreben
von Gerhard Strate aufzuzeigen dass auch
ein anderer Täter in Frage kommen kann
und darauf stützt sich hauptsächlich das
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren der mögliche
Täter lebt aktuell noch in Amerika
Monika Weimar setzt große Hoffnung da
rein weil das natürlich auch ihre
Unschuld die sie immer noch beteuert
unterstreichen könnte wenn sich etwas
tut in diesem Fall werden wir euch in
diesem Podcast darüber berichten
versprochen wir haben den Fall mit den
Aufzeichnungen von Lena Zander erzählt
sowie mit den Archiven von Bild und Welt
hilfreich war auch die chronologische
Auflistung des Falls durch die Website
des Literaturkritikers Dieter wunderlich
es gibt Stefan Netzeband Postproduktion
durch die weltweit Studios München
schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei wart bis
zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und euer
Stefan